I've been talking about Trump voters
being completely bamboozled by Donald
Trump since his election Donald Trump
has stepped away from many of the
campaign promises and then the campaign
promises he's gone forward with our of
course being carried out in a way that
is deliberately designed not to actually
accomplish the stated goals of those
policies but rather to appeal again to
the low information Trumpets who will
see it as a box checked off on the
campaign promise list we have some
fascinating new polling data from PPP
and it pulled all Americans and then
broke down certain beliefs and opinions
based on whether one was a trump
supporter or not these trumpets are so
confused they don't think they're
confused they think they found the real
truth amid a completely confusing world
of so-called fake news but it is amazing
how these folks have been bamboozled
into thinking things that just aren't
true let's go through some of the data
from this poll Pat let's start first
with the general question do you approve
or disapprove of president Jeong Trump's
job performance and 44 percent approved
these numbers match the recent Gallup
poll that I told you about with an ax
pointer to Donald Trump reaching more
than 50 percent disapproval in only 8
days which is really a genuinely notable
accomplishment for a president okay next
question
what is your opinion of the women who
participated in marches across the
country this week this is of all
Americans 50% half of all Americans have
a favorable opinion of the women's
marches okay very good let's continue
next question is do you think Donald
Trump's inauguration had the biggest
crowd of any presidential inauguration
in history 62% of respondents correctly
identified that no Donald Trump's
inauguration crowd was not the biggest
in presidential history just under one
in 518 percent of all respondents
thought yes Donald Trump had to be
biggest crowd of any in presidential
inauguration history we know that that
is wrong right we know that that is an
incorrect
we keep that in mind next what do you
think had a bigger crowd the women's
March or Donald Trump's inauguration by
a Thrym slim majority most people
getting this right 54% of all Americans
believe that yes the women's March had
more attendance than Donald Trump's
inauguration that is correct it did
indeed 29 percent of all respondents
believe that Trump's inauguration had
more people show up okay here is where
the data starts to get a little bit
scary we are now going to look at the
numbers among Trump voters this is
incredibly disturbing okay
among Trump voters do you think Trump's
inauguration had the biggest crowd of
any presidential inauguration in history
a plurality of Trump voters believe that
yes
Trump's inauguration had record-setting
crowd now this is directly connected to
the misinformation campaign carried out
by Donald Trump and Sean Spicer and
Kellyanne Conway the epitome of
alternative facts and indeed you'll
notice that 34 percent say yes Trump had
the biggest crowd 32% say no that's only
66 percent that's because 34 percent of
people are just completely confused and
they don't know they don't know what the
truth is okay so the most common
response here is that yes indeed Trump
had the biggest crowd of any
presidential inauguration in history
according to trump supporters just wrong
a plurality between yes and no said yes
Trump had the biggest crap let's
continue here among Trump voters do you
think Trump or Obama had a bigger crowd
for his inauguration 43% of Trump voters
believe that Donald Trump had a bigger
crowd than President Obama during his
inauguration completely untrue not even
close
Donald Trump a far smaller crowd
inauguration crowd than Barack Obama
okay you might be saying well listen it
doesn't really matter what people's
opinion is of the crowd let's look at
some other issues okay well let's do
exactly that a bigger crowd women's
March or Trump inauguration among Trump
voters stunning 59% of Trump voters
believe that Donald Trump's inauguration
had a larger
out than the women's March this could
not be more false Pat and this now goes
to the credibility of the women's March
which has been attacked significantly by
the right I've issued microts criticisms
of the women's March but by and large
overwhelmingly larger crowds they're six
out of ten
trumpets believe that Trump's pathetic
inauguration attendance was bigger than
the women's March attendance it's
amazing how in 2017 we need polling
information on this we have the raw data
to show how many people attended Trump's
inauguration how many people attended
Obama's and the women's March but
somehow even though we have those raw
data we still have to interview people
and ask their opinions on this and get
incredibly disturbing answers I would
add yeah okay and then lastly I think
this is the last one among Trump voters
probably the most insane do you think
most of the women most of the women who
protested this weekend were paid to do
so by George Soros 38% a plurality of
Trump voters believe that yes most of
the women protesting in the women's
March were paid by George Soros to do so
Trump supporters once again living up to
their long-running reputation of being
gullible and misinformed
Kellyanne Conway's alternative facts in
action this is very disconcerting if
it's any indication of what's to come
for the remainder of Donald Trump's term
if Trump supporters are going to
continue being this malleable and and
manipulatable a Trump's team is going to
be able to bend reality for their low
information supporters because they eat
it up now are the Trump supporters
believing the lies because they really
just believe anything the Trump
administration tells them or are they
answering these polls by going through
the questions and getting the most Trump
answer they can find for optics purposes
I don't know but this still supports the
notion that the Trump presidency the
Trump candidacy and now the presidency
is based on blindness and falsehoods and
a sort of denial of basic provable facts
these are not amorphous or hard to pin
down realities these are just simple
facts
I think it's also amazing to compare the
polling among the entire American public
versus just Donald Trump supporters
yeah there's such a stark difference
there I mean it just goes to show that
really a slim minority of people support
Trump yes indeed and it matters not only
because of that but also because we like
to think if Trump does crazy stuff he'll
suffer the consequences he must right I
mean the Republican Party controls
everything anything that goes wrong
under Trump it's going to hurt Trump but
at the same time it seems as though that
isn't necessarily going to be the case
this will be a major uphill battle
because Donald Trump and Kellyanne
Conway and Bannon and Spicer they have
successfully primed trumpets to believe
anything that comes out of the
administration's mouths or Twitter
accounts or wherever with no critical
thinking whatsoever applied Trump can
actually lose the battle to make America
great again but win the propaganda war
and that should be really concerning to
anybody not on a partisan basis but
anybody who believes that we should have
a public that believes simple provable
facts major uphill battle that we're
fighting here send me your thoughts I'm
on Twitter at des Pakman today's show is
brought to you by go daddy where you can
buy your own domain name build a website
or use any of Go Daddy's business tools
you can save 30 percent at Tri
godaddy.com slash David GoDaddy has
actually been the official host of the
David Pakman show website for many many
many years the 24/7 customer support has
been a very good thing for us I've
called them at really odd times when
we've had website issues and they are
always available they are the largest
domain registrar and whether you have a
new idea you're an established business
you're creating a personal website or
moving your large enterprise site over
to GoDaddy they can do it all thirteen
million customers try it and get 30% off
at try go daddy.com slash David